en este vídeo veremos otro ejemplo de la
descomposición en fracciones parciales y
en este caso haremos el inciso b 4 x + 9
entre x menos uno por x más 1 por x 4 y
como anteriormente primero vamos a
reescribir la expresión original tenemos
4 x + 9 / x menos uno por x + 1 por x +
4 y esto está perfecto porque el
denominador ya está factor izado así que
podemos pasar directamente a la
descomposición de la fracción en este
caso la vamos a descomponer en tres
fracciones en la primera el denominador
es x menos 1 en la segunda tenemos x + 1
y en la tercera tenemos x + 4 entonces
cada factor se convierte en una fracción
individual y arriba simplemente vamos a
colocar las constantes a b
ok entonces nuestro objetivo en este
problema es calcular el valor de a b y c
y lo haremos de la misma forma que en el
ejemplo anterior primero necesitamos
deshacernos de los denominadores y eso
lo podemos lograr
multiplicando ambos lados de la ecuación
por todo lo que tenemos en el
denominador en la fracción original en
este caso vamos a multiplicar por x
menos 1 por x + 1 por x 4 y como lo
estamos multiplicando del lado izquierdo
también hay que multiplicarlo del lado
derecho entonces por x menos 1 por x más
1 por x 4 ahora observen que del lado
izquierdo todo se cancela y nos queda 4
x más 9 que es lo que queríamos desde el
principio y ahora del lado derecho
cuando multiplicamos todo esto por cada
uno de estos términos al multiplicar x
menos 1 x x 1 x x 4 por el primero
x 1 se cancela y por lo tanto nos queda
a por x 1 por x 4 + b por vamos a ver si
multiplicamos por el segundo término x +
1 se cancela y nos queda x menos 1 por x
4 y finalmente al multiplicar todo por
el tercer término x 4 se cancela y nos
queda c por x 1 por x + 1 ok ahora
podríamos usar el procedimiento de
igualar los coeficientes pero como
podemos ver que todos los términos son
lineales podemos usar el atajo que vimos
en el vídeo anterior así que vamos a
sustituir los valores que necesitamos de
x eso nos simplifica mucho las cosas en
este caso los valores de x que nos
convienen usar son por ejemplo si
sustituimos x x menos 1 eso nos
permitirá deshacernos de algunos
términos y si aplicamos que x
igual a 4 eso nos ayudará a deshacernos
de algunos otros términos y si también
aplicamos que x sea igual a 1 positivo
podemos deshacernos de otros términos
simplemente estamos pensando en cómo
hacer que algunos de estos factores sea
cero empecemos con x igual a menos 1
supongamos que x es igual a menos 1
vamos a sustituirlo en toda la ecuación
entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos 4 x
menos uno que es igual a menos 4 más
9 y ahora observen que al sustituir x
igual a menos 1 del lado derecho donde
tengamos el término x + 1 será igual a 0
así que aquí obtendremos a x 0 con lo
que se va y después tenemos b x vamos a
ver menos uno menos uno por menos uno
más cuatro y finalmente cuando pasamos
al ac al sustituir menos uno en el
último término nuevo
obtenemos 0 así que lo único con lo que
nos quedamos es del lado izquierdo nos
queda menos 49 que es igual a 5 y del
lado derecho
ahí se se van y nos quedamos con b x
vamos a ver menos uno menos uno es igual
a menos dos y menos uno más cuatro es
igual a tres entonces menos dos por tres
es igual a menos seis y si dividimos
ambos lados entre menos seis nos queda
que d es igual a menos cinco entre seis
ok ya tenemos una de las constantes
ahora hagamos lo mismo pero como ya
sustituimos x igual a menos 1 ahora
veamos qué pasa si x es igual a menos 4
entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos 4 x
menos 49 y del lado derecho al sustituir
x igual a menos 4 el primer término será
igual a cero y miren también obtendremos
0 en el segundo término así que nos
quedamos con
por menos cuatro menos uno por menos
cuatro más uno calculemos del lado
izquierdo nos queda cuatro por menos
cuatro que es menos 16 y menos 16 9 es
igual a menos 7 y del lado derecho
tenemos menos 4 menos uno que es igual a
menos 5 y aquí nos queda menos 3 así que
menos 5 por menos 3 es igual a 15 y
ahora simplemente dividimos ambos lados
entre 15 y nos queda que se es igual a
menos 7 entre 15 a y tenemos otro de
nuestros valores y finalmente vamos a
repetir el proceso una vez más pero
ahora sustituyendo x igual a 1 entonces
al sustituir x igual a 1 del lado
izquierdo
nos queda 49 y del lado derecho nos
queda a por 11 por 14 y observen que al
sustituir x 1
cuando termino será igual a 0 y lo mismo
ocurre con el tercer término también
será igual a cero así que del lado
izquierdo nos queda 13 y del lado
derecho tenemos a por 11 que es igual a
2 por 14 que es igual a 5 entonces 2 por
5 es igual a 10 y si dividimos ambos
lados entre 10 nos queda que a es igual
a 13 entre 10
ahí está ya calculamos a b y c
entonces la descomposición en fracciones
parciales al reescribir lo que teníamos
originalmente nos queda como bueno ya
conocemos a que es igual a 13 entre 10 y
todo eso entre x menos uno más el valor
de b entre x uno
el valor de c / x 4 y ya sabemos que el
valor de c es menos 7 entre 15 y que el
valor de b es menos 5 entre 6 y eso es
lo que escribimos arriba de x + 1 menos
5 en 36 así es como hemos resuelto la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
de esta expresión racional y recuerden
que si juntan todos los denominadores
comunes podrán regresar a la fracción
que teníamos originalmente así que esta
es nuestra respuesta final
esta es la descomposición en fracciones
parciales